so today we're gonna go back to the
reddit relationship forum and answer
some more questions
from some more hopelessly clueless
people looking for relationship guidance
on reddit
and look you guys know i i'm coming out
this from the perspective of a married
man
ten years in four kids so you know i
think i think i'm pretty realistic if
nothing else
my advice may not be comforting may not
be polite it may not be correct
but i'm gonna give it to you straight so
let's take a look
first question i feel like my girlfriend
is cheating on me and messaging other
guys on instagram
does anyone know how i can get into her
account since she doesn't give me her
phone
and changes the topic every time by the
way there are no periods or any
punctuation
at all in that whole question anyway is
your girlfriend cheating on
you probably yeah she probably is i mean
chances are pretty good look it's not
her responsibility to hand her phone
over to you in the first place she's not
your child but
if you're noticing some weird secrecy
around phones and messaging and
that sort of thing 99 chance that it's
exactly what you think it is i hate to
tell you
so this is one where i would say
probably
best to break up probably heading that
way anyway
regardless of the cheating or the
potential cheating so i would i would
simply break up
okay next question so i've been on three
dates with this girl and we're really
clicking and i really like her and she
just agreed to a fourth date tomorrow
and it's been about less than two weeks
since we started talking
point is every now and then she goes off
for a good few hours
and i don't know i'm in all sorts of
stress i don't want to say anything to
her about it because i don't want to
overwhelm or seem needy but i need to be
able to healthily deal with this
and i just instantly run through
scenarios that she's not into me or so
and so
are some people just not into texting i
don't know
do i just need to chill the f out listen
there's nothing more repulsive to a
woman than neediness in a man
that is the most repulsive trait is to
be needy
so you you are being repulsive in the
eyes of this woman
but the problem is that phones and text
messaging and all of that
stuff just ignites this kind of
neediness in people so i'm not really
blaming you for this
and and and like everyone is is like
this to a certain extent at this point
not just in relationships the very fact
that the other person has their phone on
them at all times
means that you feel like and not just
you but universally
you feel like you're entitled to their
attention all the time
because they have on them the means by
which you can get their attention right
but you aren't i mean you can't just
barge in on someone at all
hours of the day relentlessly whenever
you feel like it and expect that they'll
drop everything they're doing
and respond to you it's insane but it's
an insanity that you're you're a good
company because like most of the country
this is how they operate if they send a
text message they expect an immediate
response
you know i frequently get text messages
and i don't respond to them for days
i treat text messages like like their
letters and i'm living on the frontier
in in 1835 and the male comes by
horseback every four months
i give myself that kind of time to
respond to a text message that's what i
do you know why
because i don't owe you a response i
don't owe you my attention
i'm doing something i'm in the middle of
something leave me alone
or maybe i'm in the middle of nothing
maybe i'm literally just sitting on a
chair
staring at a wall and you send me a text
message you know what i'm still gonna do
i'm gonna look at my phone
and just put it down and not respond
because i don't feel like talking right
now if i felt like talking i'd be
texting you
you see look the point is this girl
doesn't exist simply to respond to you
if you want that
go ask for a date from siri okay see if
alexa is still single
you want a human being then let them
live a life
apart from your constant surveillance
get a grip but yeah she might be
cheating on you too that's also possible
all right this says my boyfriend and i
are compatible but not soul mates
not sure what to do we first met i knew
he wasn't the one for me
we have literally nothing in common he
likes football computers
staying home quiet time movies i like
adventuring outdoors art exploring okay
so
when you first met you knew he wasn't
the one for you but you started dating
got it good good good plan when we go
out and do anything together it's never
fun
it's never spontaneous okay so let me
stop again
you met this guy you knew he wasn't the
one for you you never once had fun with
him
and yet you decided to date him okay
it's never anything we both like to do
the only activity we can both agree on
is watching tv
we have differing senses of humor i
can't remember the last time he's
genuinely made me laugh okay let me stop
again
you met this guy you know he wasn't the
one for you you never had fun with him
he never made you laugh yet you still
dated him okay
i'm not saying he has no sense of humor
he's he tells jokes that i can chuckle
at but i can never have that deep belly
laugh
i know i'm supposed to want to be with
him and i do i find it comforting to
always have someone by your side at all
times
i love him with all my heart but i know
deep down that we will never be able to
just
get each other and i crave that so so so
much when i see couples on social media
or in real life
sharing the same type of humor looking
completely at ease with each other i
feel deeply resentful
feel like that feeling of romantic bliss
was taken from me it wasn't taken from
you
you chose a different path okay you
chose not to pursue it
nothing was taken from you this is a
choice that you made yourself
don't blame anybody else it's not this
guy's fault for being how he is
you know how he was you know who he was
how he was you chose to date him
so it sounds like you're just not into
this guy and you weren't from the
beginning um so the answer is to break
up obviously you never should have been
the relationship to begin with
and by the way no you don't love him
with all your heart and soul this is a
common theme that i really
read a lot on reddit and i i hear from
people too like um
yeah you know i'm with this person and i
don't get along with them i'm not into
them i have no interest
in them at all um and i want to leave
them but i love them deeply
no no you don't i mean you obviously
don't that's not
really what loving someone is all about
unless you mean in like the
universal empathetic sense of love in
the same way that you you know love your
neighbor type of thing
but you don't love them in any way aside
from that with that said
another point of course he's not your
soul mate
nobody is your soul mate you have no
soul mate
if if by soulmate you mean somebody who
you were destined to be with
somebody who's whose fate is tied to
yours
like it's written in the stars okay that
doesn't exist
at all i'll tell you when you meet your
soul mate
at the altar in marriage okay you become
a soul mate
when you say i do and your souls at that
point
become bonded through that shared
commitment
that's when the soulmate that's when you
become someone's soulmate is in marriage
but not before that and this is a really
important thing to realize you know why
because
if you go on thinking that you're
looking for that one individual person
who the universe
wants you to be with then then what
happens
when you do meet somebody and you marry
them
and then after the marriage you meet
someone else and you say oh wait a
second no
this other dude is my soul mate turns
out
i married the wrong person that's when
affairs happen
betrayal heartbreak all because of this
ridiculous
disney idea of soul mates there are no
soul mates
pre-marriage the problem with this guy
isn't that he isn't your soul mate it's
that you don't like him at all
and you never did and yeah you dated him
nicely done this one says we've been
together for six years and throughout
those i always put all my energy into
this relationship
he wouldn't initiate more than two
minutes of chat per day on his own
and if i tell him it bothers me that
only i make sure our relationship
consists of more than that he gets angry
with me
i spent the past week trying to match up
to his amount and it's been very distant
and he seems to be okay with it
i can't communicate with him about it
because he gets very angry
and i've tried many times over the last
six years i don't know if it's a
reasonable cause to break up though and
after so long
we're also supposed to move in together
in a month i just know i've been really
unhappy and i don't know what to do
moving in together is a terrible idea to
do that's terrible idea before marriage
don't do that
if you're not married to someone you
don't need to be around them 24 7 trying
to play fake marriage to play house with
someone is a bad idea
it doesn't work out i wouldn't do that
but any case as for your issue here
look there's no use in trying to even
the talking score with a guy
as a woman you are going to do almost
all the talking
because you're the woman that's your job
men could go literally eight months at a
stretch
and never say a word to anyone if you
let them i used to live alone
before i got married and if i didn't
have plans over the weekend
which i didn't most of the time uh i
could literally stay at home and go the
whole weekend without saying a single
word to anybody
my wife could not do that the words
accumulate
in her brain and if she doesn't let them
out if she doesn't open the valve
and let them out then her brain would
explode so this is why i always thought
by the way that um
castaway the movie got it wrong
because a man could easily live on a
deserted island for three years with no
social interaction and be fine
it's a woman who would need to make
friends with a volleyball
and it would be a tumultuou it'd be like
a tumultuous friendship too
you know very hot and cold they'd have a
falling out for a few weeks
a lot of fights she'd start talking
behind the volleyball's back to like the
coconuts
there'd be all kinds of complex social
interactions
and dynamics on the island even though
there's only one human there
a man on the island would be fine he'd
be rescued
after three years and the rescuer would
run up on the island and say hey
we found you we've been looking for you
for three years and he would go really
it's for three years
did i just get here last week um
finally this says this is pretty weird
and makes me feel bad but i can't help
it and i'm concerned it highlights
something underneath
basically whenever my significant other
gets me a present or recommends me in
movies things like that
i tend to dislike it immediately without
giving it the benefit of the doubt
sometimes in very irrational ways like
say they get me a book i wanted to read
or present i was actually planning on
buying myself
i'll be reading it or using the present
and subconsciously looking for reasons
to dislike it
in a way i know i wouldn't if i had
gotten it myself
as if it coming from the other person
created a dark cloud in my brain or
something
i usually try to hide these feelings i
just can't relax and enjoy the thing and
judge it the way i would
if i had bought it or chosen myself it
happened in the past with other people
like members of my family and friends
but much more intensely with my partner
has anyone experienced something similar
it's a huge problem because it often
gets
in the way of us connecting or enjoying
stuff together yeah this is called being
a miserable narcissistic person
this would be my advice if i was your
therapist and you were laying down on
the couch and describing this i would
just say stop
stop stop doing stop being that it's bad
don't be that way that'll be 100
please and also probably
you should break up